Is the system of
linear equations below
dependent or independent?
And they give us two
equations right here.
And before I tackle
this specific problem,
let's just do a little
bit a review of what
dependent or independent means.
And actually, I'll compare that
to consistent and inconsistent.
So just to start
off with, if we're
dealing with systems of linear
equations in two dimensions,
there's only three possibilities
that the lines or the equations
can have relative to each other.
So let me draw the
three possibilities.
So let me draw three
coordinate axes.
So that's my first
x-axis and y-axis.
Let me draw another one.
That is x and that is y.
Let me draw one
more, because there's
only three possibilities
in two dimensions.
x and y if we're dealing
with linear equations.
So you can have the situation
where the lines just
intersect in one point.
Let me do this.
So you could have
one line like that
and maybe the other line
does something like that
and they intersect at one point.
You could have the
situation where
the two lines are parallel.
So you could have a situation--
actually let me draw it over
here-- where you have one
line that goes like that
and the other line has the
same slope but it's shifted.
It has a different y-intercept,
so maybe it looks like this.
And you have no points
of intersection.
And then you could
have the situation
where they're actually the same
line, so that both lines have
the same slope and
the same y-intercept.
So really they
are the same line.
They intersect on an
infinite number of points.
Every point on
either of those lines
is also a point
on the other line.
So just to give you a little
bit of the terminology here,
and we learned this in the
last video, this type of system
where they don't intersect,
where you have no solutions,
this is an inconsistent system.
And by definition, or
I guess just taking
the opposite of
inconsistent, both of these
would be considered consistent.
But then within consistent,
there's obviously a difference.
Here we only have one solution.
These are two different lines
that intersect in one place.
And here they're essentially
the same exact line.
And so we differentiate
between these two scenarios
by calling this one
over here independent
and this one over
here dependent.
So independent-- both lines
are doing their own thing.
They're not dependent
on each other.
They're not the same line.
They will intersect
at one place.
Dependent-- they're
the exact same line.
Any point that satisfies one
line will satisfy the other.
Any points that
satisfies one equation
will satisfy the other.
So with that said, let's see if
this system of linear equations
right here is dependent
or independent.
So they're kind of
having us assume
that it's going
to be consistent,
that we're going to
intersect in one place
or going to intersect in an
infinite number of places.
And the easiest way to
do this-- we already
have this second equation here.
It's already in
slope-intercept form.
We know the slope is negative
2, the y-intercept is 8.
Let's put this first equation
up here in slope-intercept form
and see if it has a different
slope or a different intercept.
Or maybe it's the same line.
So we have 4x plus
2y is equal to 16.
We can subtract 4x
from both sides.
What we want to do is isolate
the y on the left hand side.
So let's subtract
4x from both sides.
The left hand side-- we
are just left with a 2y.
And then the right hand side,
we have a negative 4x plus 16.
I just wrote the negative
4 in front of the 16,
just so that we have it in the
traditional slope-intercept
form.
And now we can divide both
sides of this equation
by 2, so that we can isolate
the y on the left hand side.
Divide both sides by 2.
We are left with y is equal
to negative 4 divided by 2
is negative 2x plus
16 over 2 plus 8.
So all I did is algebraically
manipulate this top equation up
here.
And when I did that, when
I solved essentially for y,
I got this right
over here, which
is the exact same thing
as the second equation.
We have the exact same slope,
negative 2, negative 2,
and we have the exact
same y-intercept, 8 and 8.
If I were to graph these
equations-- that's my x-axis,
and that is my y-axis-- both
of them have a y-intercept at 8
and then have a
slope of negative 2.
So they look
something-- I'm just
drawing an approximation of it--
but they would look something
like that.
So maybe this is the graph
of this equation right
here, this first equation.
And then the second equation
will be the exact same graph.
It has the exact
same y-intercept
and the exact same slope.
So clearly these two
lines are dependent.
They have an infinite
number of points
that are common to both of them,
because they're the same line.